thank you
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
this meeting of weber licensing and
regulatory committee
i am councillor margaret mabry chairman
of the licensing and regulatory
committee and i will be chairing the
meeting today
may i first
remind you all of some of the domestic
arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distance from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face mask
or face covering at all times unless you
are seated
or if you are exempt from doing so and
that you use the hand sanitizer and
wipes
provided you will be invited to speak
and ask questions by the chair please do
not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting
you may be asked to leave
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please ensure mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
additionally we will be using evoting on
the modern.gov app for this meeting
please good members therefore ensure
they are logged in and ready to use the
app
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
thank you
i now introduce the members who are here
today the officers in particular
attending meeting are catherine green
licensing officer to my right
kay sanders
licensing officer who's now moved to the
second tier
nigel dulu legal officer to my left
karen sayer governance officer
behind me to my left
we also have emma richbelt on the tier 2
we have
the corporate manager
on tier 3 alongside the chief executive
of baber district council
and i thank them all for attending
will now move on to the agenda apologies
for absence
are there any apologies please
karen thank you chair we've received
apologies from councillor creswell
councillor grandin councillor newman and
councillor nunn and councillor dawson
has advised that she may arrive late
thank you very thank you very much um
i will add that there are quite a few
absentees today from members sadly some
are unwell and i send my best wishes to
them
item two declaration of interest by
councillors
are there any declarations yes
councillor beer
[Applause]
just um on your previous point
councillor newman did ask me to point
out that um
the reason he couldn't make it this
afternoon is that friday afternoons it's
very difficult for him to get away uh
he was on the impression that was friday
morning but i know you're going to look
into that anyway
thank you
um yes thank you
thank you councillor beer i am looking
at the timings of these meetings um and
thank you for pointing that out
thank you
any declarations of interest by
councillors
nope thank you i'll move on to item
three to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 16th of august 2021
would counsellors like
thank you counselor
carpenter you have something please
yes
i just propose the minutes are accepted
and term
thank you very much councillor we've had
a proposal
and the second is councillor beer thank
you very much
the
governance officer will now conduct the
electronic vote
thank you chair councillors please can
you open the vote in the modern.gov app
by clicking on the plus sign in the top
right of the agenda screen
the vote for this item will now show in
blue
um councillor ayers
thank you for saying that you wish to to
abstain that's quite a newt point
actually because councillors can
vote for minutes i believe even if you
weren't attending previously you you can
vote for the minutes
thank you that's our legal officer who's
just given a
decision on that thank you that's a very
um gray area that you can actually vote
on minutes even if you were not
attending it really depends on how you
feel but thank you
thank you chair that's um three votes
for and two abstentions
you would like to change yours to a four
that's four four and one abstention
chair
thank you uh thank you very much um the
minutes have now been confirmed and will
be signed at the end of the meeting
thank you very much
item four is to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
none received chair thank you very much
we move on to item five which is
questions by councillors are there any
please none receive chair thank you very
much
and item six on the agenda
is
blr stroke 2-1 stroke 8 is the gambling
act 2005
statement of principles statutory
three-year revision
i will now invite the licensing officer
catherine to introduce the report to the
committee
thank you
thank you chair
the purpose of this report is to report
back to the licensing and regulatory
committee the outcome of a full targeted
and public consultation which ran
between the 20th of august 2021 and the
16th of september 2021 in respect to the
above statutory policy revision relating
to gambling act 2005 functions
this report seeks the approval by the
licensing and regulatory committee of
the revised principle statement now
attaches appendix a for recommendation
onto full council so that it may be
adopted for publication and ready to
take effect from the 31st of january
2022
this is a statutory requirement to
review and re-adopt the council's
gambling policy a summary of the changes
made brought to this committee on the
16th of august 2021 from the 2019
statement
to the redraft is attached to this
report as appendix b
the sixth edition of the statement of
principles once approved and adopted
shall take effect for a three-year
period from the 31st of january 2022
although it may be revised sooner if
necessary it will then become a primary
point of reference for councillors
officers applicants and other
responsible or interested parties
following the consultation exercise baby
received one response and this is
attached to this report as appendix c
from the responses received there are no
further necessary changes which need to
be made to the draft statement of
principles
therefore the recommendation is that the
post-consultation draft statement of
principles in respect of gambling act
2005 functions as attached to appendix a
be approved and that the committee makes
recommendation to full council that the
statement of principles document be
adopted this concludes my report
thank you very much catherine um i would
just like to comment that the one
response that we did receive was from um
be gambler ware
so they have actually made a comment
about how
gambling
interacts with
society so thank you for that
are there any questions for the
licensing officer please for members
councillor beer
thank you madam chairman um can i first
of all i i've been through this and i i
can remember way back
um
2014-12 it could even been earlier when
we took over the gambling bits and
pieces
does this include casinos in our area
is that reference in this
document because i've been through it
and i i couldn't actually say it
but um
i know we haven't got any casinos in our
area
um but uh would that be amongst this if
we did have them
um councillor beer i can i can answer
that
um the licenses for
casinos are allocated by
government
um and we do not have a license for any
casinos in baber or in mid-suffolk so
that's a policy that does not currently
apply to baber
my next question is
could i ask through you to the officers
is there anything in particular
because when i went through it i could
see the bits that had been crossed out
and would have been added and that seems
sort of like updating but is there
anything
that you consider of great importance
that we should be very aware of
i know put the emphasis on you but you
know when you start reading this at the
beginning you get to the end of it all
you've forgotten what the first part was
catherine please respond yeah if i may
thank you chair so um in in regards to
the summary of changes we took into
account the um
the guidance submitted by the gambling
commission that they give to licensing
authorities it's very minimal changes a
lot of the
amendments have been made are past
grammatical errors and potential header
errors if i may refer back to your
original question about casinos as well
we do reference them in our um our
statement of principles but as
councilman quite rightly said there is
no allocation left available for casinos
um nationally so therefore
it's not too much of an
issue for the baby district
thank you very much
councillor cartondale
thank you chair um
can we just be assured that in fact
there's no material difference
in this
version of the policy from the previous
policy that we have and it is just very
small adjustments
and
in in that sense also is there any
material change to the context
in which the policy has been put
together
i.e has the environment of gambling
change
and catherine please respond
thank you chair um as far as the team
aware that the gambling provisions we
have currently available hasn't changed
dramatically in our district we have
very low levels of gambling
um the and the changes that were made as
i say were in conjunction with those
that were proposed under the guidance
from the gambling commission so we've
not gone too too fast
would we like to open this up
to debate council beer
would anyone like to debate this paper
nope thank you councillor beer has um
proposed the office's recommendations
and the second is uh councillor
carpenter
and we can vote please
thank you
thank you chair councillors can you
please open the vote in the modern.gov
app
and the vote for this agenda item will
now show in blue
councillors would you like to be
reminded of what we're voting for are
you all quite
happy all quite happy thank you very
much
that's five votes for chair
i think thank you very much karen um the
governor's officer has declared that
that's a unanimous vote so thank you
very much
item seven on the agenda is blr stroke
two one stroke nine new hackney carriage
and private tyre vehicle licensing
policy
i will now invite the licensing officer
catherine to introduce the report to the
committee
please
thank you chair
the purpose of this report is to report
back to the licensing and regulatory
committee the outcome of a full targeted
and public consultation
which ran between the 20th of august
2021 and the 16th of september 2021 in
respect to the hackney carriage and
private hire vehicle licensing policy
for the controlled zone of baba district
council
following the publication of the new
statutory standards for taxis and
private hire vehicles
councils are required to review the
recommendations from the department for
transport and consult on any changes to
the current policies
on the 21st of july 2020 the dft
published its long-awaited statutory
standards for taxi and private hire
licensing
the new standards brought in a raft of
recommendations and requirements which
councils must have regard to
in exercising their functions under
hackney carriage and private hire
vehicle licensing
the standards are also replaced relevant
sections of the best practice guidance
issued by the dft in 2010 where there is
a conflict between the standards and
best practice the standards will take
precedence
the dft will update its best practice
guidance for councils in due course
however in the meantime it expects
councils to adopt its recommendations in
the news standards document so that past
failings of some licensing regimes are
never repeated
whilst the focus of the new statutory
taxi and private hire vehicle standards
is on protecting children and vulnerable
adults all passengers will benefit from
the recommendations contained in it
there is consensus that common core
minimum standards are required to better
regulate the taxi and private hire
vehicle sector
the overarching aim of the statutory
standards is public protection
adoption of the hackney carriage and
private hire vehicle licensing policy is
a function reserved for cabinet
following the consultation exercise baba
received 14 responses and these are
attached to this report as appendix b
office's responses to the comments from
consultees are attached to this report
as appendix c
and for ease of reference some common
themes have been color coded from the
responses received the changes made are
attached as appendix d therefore the
recommendations are as follows
that the post-consultation draft hackney
carriage and private hire vehicle
licensing policy attached to appendix a
be approved
and that the committee makes
recommendation to cabinet that the
hackney carriage and private hire
vehicle licensing policy document be
adopted and this concludes my report
thank you very much catherine for that
members are there any questions that you
would like to raise for catherine at the
moment
councillor coppendale thank you thank
you um i believe that and the very large
response to the responses there are some
um
comments that that changes might
actually be made to the
document is that right
and if so can we can we just accept that
they will be made
yes so um the the changes that we're
proposing are all listed under appendix
d so we've also gone through the policy
as well and highlighted anything we were
taking out in red we've read and struck
it out and anything we're um adding is
in blue so the policy and under appendix
a and the summary document document of
appendix d are basically across the
board and if you are to
prove that they will be made yeah
thank you catherine um any other
questions from members
councilor beer
thank you um yes that reminded me um
when councillor cartendale said
something there um
one of the responses uh on page 116
um
you know
is that relevant they're saying that um
by introducing this new policy it's
going to make life very difficult and
more expensive for them to replace their
vehicles
um because of the um um
disabled
of wheelchair accessibility surrey
that they they've got to conform with
i thought this
only happened if you had over a certain
amount of vehicles am i wrong here that
you can help me out counselor um
catherine would you like to respond
yeah thank you chair
um we amend as part of the the policy
review we've amended a condition and as
part of the policy that any vehicle that
is going to be eight seats will be
wheelchair accessible as well over the
both private hire and hackney carriage
this was due to responses we received
from the disability uh suffolk
disability forum who did a survey for us
and the result of that was that a lot of
disabled people prefer to pre-book with
an operator and there is a lacking in
terms of wheelchair accessible vehicles
in the private hire vehicle sector
so we're actually forcing them to comply
with this
um i wouldn't say forcing you can still
have a larger a larger vehicle um but
you can opt for seven seats and not have
to follow the wheelchair accessibility
requirement it's just they're saying if
you want an eight-seater vehicle it
needs to also be wheelchair access but
according to
uh this particular um
person responding um that would be more
expensive for them if they had to go for
a seven-seater rather than an
eight-seater
so
it does seem a little bit hard
but
i know we have to move and i know we
have to take this on board but i wonder
whether we're being a bit heavy-handed
if i'm fma chair
quite a significant number of hackney
carriage proprietors already own
wheelchair accessible vehicles because
of the current stipulations anyway we've
saturated the hackney carriage market
with
very large wheelchair accessible
vehicles and as per the the disability
forum response not many um
disabled people from the responses
received are using the hackney carriage
rank space so this is hopefully going to
level out the market as it were
could i just follow on from that weather
did we have many comments from
members of the public who are in this
category saying that they
they couldn't get the taxis because of
the um you know they weren't
adaptable enough
i mean
you know it's all very well for an
organization to come forward and say
they want this but if if the actual
resident out there a wheelchair resident
isn't complaining to us about it
and they haven't really responded from
what i could see going through this
um
do we still need to do this to this
degree i suppose that's why bottom line
that's right response thank you
um so
um the the organization did a
pre-consultation consultation with all
of their members as part of the suffolk
disability forum and they shared the
results with us we're not able to
provide that because it was all done as
a confidential um survey with with
regards to their members but they fed
that back to us that we were able to be
fully informed with our policy
um
as i say we don't feel that it's too
harsh a condition because at the moment
they're already being forced to buy a
wheelchair accessible vehicle for any
that vehicles are plated 21 and over
therefore by having this condition it
gives them a little bit more uh leeway
as to what vehicles that they will use
and if you desperately want the
eight-seater we don't feel it's too
unnecessary to ask for it to be
wheelchair accessible
thank you councillor come back please do
i don't think you've actually answered
my question i take the point i
understand where you come from but if
we're not getting members of the public
uh who
need um who are
sort of lead wheelchairs and what have
you if they're not coming forward
telling us that
the taxes they use and can't provide
this
why are we going down this road to this
degree that's my point if you can say to
me yes we we do know of many people who
have complained that they haven't been
able to get a taxi with that that's a
different story but um
if we're if we're sam well this is what
should be happening and uh if they get
an eight seater they've got to have a uh
this wheels chair accessibly friendly um
but no one's going to use it
um thank you councillor i'm actually
going to respond here if if that's all
right and catherine um will will help me
out
um this policy uh will will be for
the next few years and really it is
trying to anticipate the future need as
well as the need at the moment i
understand where you're coming from it
would always be really good if members
of the public actually responded to the
items that we're trying to raise and
that we're trying to
for one of a better word level out
but sadly we haven't had them without
the confidential report so we cannot
include them
it's always a very
it's always very difficult to balance
out
the needs of those who perhaps
may
talk loudly and those who may talk
quietly
um and i think this is the way that
probably
we will be helping those who may not
wish to draw attention to the fact that
they are less abled
um and this is a way forward catherine
would you like to add anything to that
please
thank you chair we've we've not received
any responses from any members of the
public but we found through
other
policy reviews that we've done that we
don't really get
any if at all from members of the public
so we felt that the fact that
at least some people had managed to
contribute via the suffolk disability
forum was enough to really inform
us in regards to reviewing the policy
and if i may add to help you counselor
beer um it has been reported to me that
some less able people actually prefer to
use the sala um
a saloon car
because they find it easier to
get into an exit enter and exit
um so i think that
this balancing act
helps to make sure that we have the
vehicles on the on the road for trade
that can be used for wheelchair users
who cannot remove themselves for the
wheelchair but there are also the saloon
cars that those who are less able may
like to use
any other questions
oh sorry councilors missed you i beg
your pardon um response 10 or land
response 9 um about some drivers having
to take a vtec
qualification there seems to be quite a
bit of
um
trouble about it particularly we're
looking for drivers now would you like
to
give us some information on that please
catherine
[Music]
you councillor
um the the b tech is um
is being proposed uh in a way to um
fully qualify um all drivers um across
the board in the necessary information
that they need to know um the
safeguarding standards have brought in
the requirement of needing to know um
safeguarding in particular child
exploitation um and um county lines and
there's also um the need for disability
awareness which the course will
encompass
it's i know that there is also responses
that state that they've been drivers for
a while so what would be the need but it
just means that if everybody undertakes
that they'll be at the same
the same level
thank you catherine i'm going to respond
on this
quite quite a few of the responses that
we've had from the taxi trade have
actually covered this point that they
have been taxi drivers for many years
and we we thank them for that their
service to the community
and they are a bit um concerned about
having perhaps to do this training
um
i think it's fair to point out that this
is a statutory requirement
laid down by government it's not
something that we can bypass even if we
would wish to
i will add and this is going to be
controversial and i have spoken to the
team
that perhaps we as a council should be
looking at for one year only
to perhaps subsidize the amount of money
that they have to pay for this training
for one year only and it is something
that i will be asking the cabinet to
actually look at
um the current cost for this
btec which is over two days so obviously
taxi drivers are going to lose money for
two days the actual cost is 150 pounds
we have um i think we
calculated about 200
tax licensed taxi drivers within the
district so that would amount to about
30 000 pounds
if the council would consider ever
subsidizing the amount
that they have to pay this is something
that we can perhaps recommend to cabinet
and it is up to other members to see if
they are in agreement with this it
doesn't actually have to be the hundred
percent it could be a percentage but for
one year only and that would be my
recommendation would members like to
comment on that please
oh councillor beer i think you missed me
thank you thank you um
is this
um
test a refresher course every three
years or five years that's the first
part
it's every three years
well
i i don't consider that's too
unreasonable in in my previous life
i had to
take a
test every four years
and um
and then it was about 350 pounds at a
time
and
i was always
believed that you could always learn
something pick something new up and
sometimes we just get a little bit um
you know we've done it so much you just
forget some of the things that you
shouldn't forget um
yeah that's the word complacent thank
you um but
uh yes i don't think we can give sort of
grandfather right but i do think three
years is rather too short
um i would like that to be a bit longer
um i i think if someone's done a
refresher course which they should be
encouraged to do
say every four years or five years um
that should be sufficient
um and because
you know it does take time out of your
work and day and i had to pay all my own
costs myself and that was
sometimes
a couple of days
and
it was very expensive then heaven knows
what it is now in in that particular
industry but uh yes i i do some sympathy
here that i feel yes the test and the
refresher course is useful and i don't
think any of them would really object to
that because you can always learn
something but i think the timing of
three years should be increased to at
least four um thank you councillor beer
and we we appreciate your experience um
within the
motor industry i'm going to call it or
the motor services so thank you very
much
i believe that's a statutory three-year
period um i'll ask catherine to confirm
i may have got it wrong
i don't believe it's to be a statutory
three-year period the reasoning behind
the setting of the three years is when
you are issued a driver badge it runs
for a three-year period so we were
hoping to do
a three-year period with a refresher
course at the end of their three
the third year that way it would fall in
line with when we're doing renewals i
understand wholeheartedly what you're
saying though about making it a little
bit longer it just would then fall
outside of their normal everyday renewal
but
chairman that wouldn't
yes it would fall outside that but it's
not impossible for us to accommodate
that and i'd still like to say we should
go to at least four years
um
murrayfield was teaching people to drive
and examining them and all that and they
felt four years was adequate there i
would have thought that four years for
taxi driver who's doing the same thing
basically all the time
uh would it should be the minimum
thank you very much councillor bf um
for that that comment um have any other
members
any
questions for catherine before we go
into debate please
nope um thank you
so we will we will move into debate and
i'm going to ask members if they have
any thoughts on what councilor beer has
has proposed
tentatively
at the moment councillor ayers thank you
i think um it's a sound suggestion
about them having some paid towards it
or maybe the taxi company i mean you've
got big taxi companies and you've got
the odd individuals
so i don't know quite how we would even
that out but yes i do think they need
help and
you always need updating i will admit i
had a speeding fine recently
and i did the online course and i
learned a lot
having driven for years so it doesn't do
anyone any harm
to
um you know to update their knowledge
and i and i did i learned a lot on this
um this course so
i thank you thank you very much um for
your for your honesty there
councillor ayers because we we can all
learn something from from training it's
never wasted
at all is anyone else any comments for
debate
councillor gould thank you
thank you madam chair
training is always good isn't it
um and it's frequently not until you've
done it that you realized how much you
needed it you don't realize how much you
need it before you've done it sometimes
um
could i am i writing thinking that the
license is up for renewal every three
years
so it would make sense for this to
level peg with that in my opinion rather
than have something else tagged on after
four years which is all a bit messy on
the timeline i think
um in terms of the suggestion for
subsidies
this is moving the goal post isn't it
that the b tech is moving the goalposts
so i think it would be sound good
practice to offer a subsidy whilst there
is that changeover period because these
taxi drivers would have started their
job without having to do this and this
is something new that has been added so
it does seem to me it would be sound
good practice to somehow subsidize it
whether it's subsidised across the board
or whether as you say councillors and
some of the bigger companies might be
able to
stand the extra expenditure more easily
in some of the others but not
necessarily because some big companies
have cash flow problems as well don't
they um so whether it could be a subsidy
that's there that people have to claim
that of course comes with it um all the
sort of you know negative stuff about
having to claim a subsidy where if it's
across the board it's much more
inclusive
um those would be my thoughts padam
chair thank you thank you very much
councillor gold
carpendale thank you
thank you chair um
i think this is a bit tricky and likely
to get a bit messy
existing drivers if they have to take
the test
more or less now
um presumably there's some way through
their three-year license
so at which point
when they start to have a renewal
i i mean you know three years from one
test to another it
doesn't sound very clear to me
when if you can help me
um catherine's going to answer that
thank you yes thank you chair so the
intention is once the policy is being
adopted um we would then look on each
driver's three yearly renewal to require
them to to go for the test
so then it would
put them into their three-year cycle
accordingly
yes please
come back
in a sense that kind of means that
existing drivers would not need to take
that test straight away they'd only need
to take it i'd be new
i would perhaps put slightly different
light on it
um i've got some sympathy with what
you're saying chair but um it might be
that we simply want to say to cabinet
would they consider
rather than actually recommending
because
um you know finding thirty thousand
um
we all know what the situation is
thank you thank you councillor for your
your comments on that thank you
any other debate on this please
no so um to move forward and i'm going
to ask the um governance officer for her
thoughts on this um we have the
recommendations
for this do we need to actually put in
another recommendation
or could we ask our legal advisor please
um
are you asking to
on the basis that there's a
proposed amendment to the recommendation
or
um are you looking for a proposal for
the original
thank you um i'm actually asking for um
if we can to do um an addition that
that um
we ask
cabinet to actually look at
discounting
the b text i don't know how we can do
this so i'm looking at you hopefully
i can see you looking at me
could i
just be before you go on yes um
the proposal regarding the subsidy
doesn't really affect
the
policy itself does it the requirement is
is that they they take these
qualifications and they acquire this
training i think the issue as to whether
there's a subsidy for it
is kind of a standalone thing and maybe
needs to be done separately um
okay
thank you thank you that and that's
really helpful and i'll just acknowledge
that councillor dawson has has joined us
and thank you very much we are actually
getting to the recommendations for
the um
for the
new hackney carriage and private hire
vehicle licensing policy
and it has been suggested that
we perhaps ask cabinet to consider
a discount
that could be applied to the taxi
drivers for the cost of their their btec
which is
150 pounds
per person
and it lasts for three years and we have
deduced that there are about 200 taxi
operators in baber um so this would
amount to if it was a full discount to
30 000 or it could be a proportion of
such that's where we are
and if you'll just excuse me a moment i
just need to have a
drink of water oh council of beer you
carry on while i'm doing this thank you
well thank you madam chairman well
um i'm not happy about has offered a
discount because
in lots of private industry people who
have qualifications have to renew them
or resit them and they have to pay them
and sometimes their companies will
help them out
but if not it is down to them it
certainly was in the profession that i
was in it was down to me no one else
would pay it so i don't think that
should be subsidised by the council but
i do think it should be four years and
i'm going to move that we um
move the motion that we
recommend
the officer's recommendation but all to
three years to four years
and um
full stop at the
question of um
support and the costs
all right thank you thank you thank you
very much councillor councillor beer any
comments on that please or anyone wish
to second that
council beer i'm very sorry to say that
you don't have a seconder so i'm very
sorry
to say this
so um we will we will go back to the
original
recommendation um i think to see
kesler carpenter to say something oh i'm
so sorry i missed you thank you
thank you i wondered if it might help
you if um i actually moved that
recommendation
to cabinet so at least we've got
something on the table
and then should members wish to or
should you wish to
perhaps not even an amendment but
possibly a second recommendation that
you might want to discuss so if i if i
move the recommendations on the paper
right
um councillor carpenter has proposed
is there a second and a second from um
councillor ayers
thank you
any other comments so far
well i will ask the government
governance officer to read out the
proposal that's on the table at the
moment which is the recommendation
um
apologies that the legal officer is just
having a word
thank you governance officer karen thank
you
thank you chair you'd like me to read
out the recommendations yes please okay
and 3.1 that the post consultation draft
hackney carriage and private hire
vehicle licensing policy attached as
appendix a to the report be approved and
a recommendation to cabinet
3.2 that the hackney carriage and
private hire vehicle licensing policy
document be adopted
thank you and if i can just ask the
legal officer we can then make a
a recommendation or we can
ask for a proposal for cabinet after
voting here
would that work
thank you thank you
so the vote will now be open
if the computers are still on
um
thank you i asked the governance officer
to um organize the vote please
thank you chair um can i just
apologize to councillor dawson you won't
be able to vote as you weren't here for
the entire item
thank you sorry
um councillors if you could please open
the vote in the app and the vote for
this item will now show in blue
sorry councillor carpenter are you
having a bit of difficulty
i can take your vote verbally counselor
carpendale if you like
thank you
that's four votes four and one against
chair
um thank you thank you very much karen
um for that so um that is carried thank
you
we now
speak if we can members as to whether we
are going to ask cabinet to consider
um a subsidy discount whatever one would
like to call it for the taxi drivers
we could ask that this is for this year
only which is
my suggestion doesn't have to be
everybody's
willing to listen to members
if anyone has any comment would they
like to comment
counsellor beer so if the three year
period
would start from now
somebody could next week be up on the
three years is that correct and they
would then have to take it
sorry uh catherine please sorry
councilman no the policies um yet to be
adopted by cabinets it's not until the
policy is actually um adopted and comes
into force that the the course
requirement becomes mandatory yeah
precisely my point so let's assume that
got the cabinet and they approved it
and they approved it today that would
come into effect then
and somebody who's three years end next
week or the beginning of next month they
would have to sit this test is that
correct
catherine that's correct counselor beer
but we have allocated a six month period
for them to to to take the assessment to
allow them time to do that right
any other comments from members
councillor gould thank you just
wondering about my maths here i think if
there's a three-year
not on affordability either
i think if there's a three year gap
there then the subsidy should be on
offer for three years
because somebody there could be a taxi
driver who
starts
the opposite from your scenario
counselor beer who who actually starts
the week before
so they would actually need to be taking
the test three years in three years time
so they would perhaps need the subsidy
we'd need the subsidy for three years
does that make sense
um
to be fully inclusive catherine did you
wish to respond
yes chess so from my understanding of
what council gold is saying if somebody
was to be licensed prior to the
implementation of the policy they
wouldn't be covered by the allocation
that you're proposing i believe that's
what you're saying yeah yes that's it
madam chair yes thank you so um thank
you thank you very thank you very much
it does
the the suggestion that i am making
perhaps may look as though it is
slightly
i'm going to use the word skewed that it
will not cover everyone
if we just did it for one year
we may suggest that it's done for for
three years
um and that there is a budget put
towards it
but it's mem it's members
consideration of this
councillor dawson
we can hear you yes yes
that's fine
can i just ask exactly how much this is
going to actually equate to a year
sort of the back of my mind wondering
why we're giving this subsidy actually
the really in in the big picture
do we really need to give it because
you know covid's we're coming to an end
of covid aren't we except yes
thank you very much councillor my i my
suggestion and has been put forward
that i have put forward and it doesn't
have to be accepted
is because
all the responses that we received
commented that
they have
in the majority been taxi
drivers for many many years
and why should they undertake this
statutory training it's something that's
set by the government there's nothing
that
we can do we
cannot set it aside for for anyone
um and yes we have had covid and they
have lost money over the last 18 months
or so and it was just a way i think of
us
suggesting to cabinet and to the taxi
trade and to our residents
that we are listening to what is
happening um and we are caring
sorry if i can just come back under
clarification
chairman um
you said listen we're not because you
commented that um
people have
said complained about the cost of this
but they've also complained about the
three-year test
you've voted that out uh voted that in i
wanted it longer and so
you know that that's the picture that
we've got we can alter it
and we chose to go three years
uh we can choose to to discount them or
not
and uh i'm of the view that
we we shouldn't be paying this discount
okay um that's fine and thank you cats
libya um for your comments council
councillor dawson i could come back to
life yeah
original question
so coming back to my original question
um does anybody know exactly i wasn't
here and why do you brought exactly how
much this if we're thinking of doing how
much is this discount per annum
in pounds pence very simply does it
equate to
it
for each driver it's 150 pounds
per person for each test it takes two
days so it's two days out of their
trading as well
and then we're going
to subsidize this to sub to subsidize it
over and there's a calculation of 200
taxi drivers
um and so that would equate to 30 000
pounds if they all took it all in one
year and my suggestion was that for this
first year only
we um supplied a
a subsidy or a discount however one
would like to put it
just just to clarify here um that the
proposal here is that it's just put to
the cabinet to consider i don't think
any decision is being made at this
committee as to whether a subsidy or a
discount will be applied
it's it's just
to be suggested to the cabinet to
consider thank you
thank you
and what is your thoughts um just
councillor dawson have you got
anything else to say
yes i'm just interested to know what the
thoughts of my colleagues are on this
councillor airs
just a suggestion council dawson could
you switch your
mic off thank you
i do think it would be a good idea to
financially assist them however you
could maybe
um
be means tested otherwise you have a big
taxi firm would claim it for everyone
and then someone who really needs the
help would not get it so if somebody
needed it maybe they could have a loan
to pay it and then pay it back um i in
my opinion that would be complicating
things but
i'm waiting for other members councillor
gould
i just wonder what we're trying to do
here
are we trying to stop tax drivers from
going out of business because they can't
afford the money for the course are we
trying to be benevolent
um so i just think perhaps we need to
give a little bit of thought to what
we're trying to do
thank you thank you for that comment
anyone else
oh councillor gold back again and i've
thought
i guess there's no evidence to suggest
that
but by
putting this subsidy in taxi drivers are
going to go out of business there's no
evidence to suggest that and there's no
evidence to suggest to the contrary
either so we're actually fumbling around
in the dark with no evidence on a
completely
thank you
thing really
yes catherine please come in thank you
chair this course isn't a new idea
either just to let councillors know that
um every other council within suffolk is
already undertaking this as part of
their normal driving procedure so we're
just
possibly behind the curve on this and if
i can ask you catherine are any
councils subsidizing it that you know of
i'm not aware but i can go and find find
that answer out for you thank you
councillor gold
thank you manager and do we know whether
any of the other councils have the
experience that some taxi drivers
haven't been able to
fund this themselves
um
thank you councillor unfortunately again
i'm not 100 aware of that i can find out
and report that back to committee
absolutely good thank you it might be
useful and then we could have a little
bit of evidence to back up what we're
doing or what we're suggesting what
we're debating really
thank you thank you any other comments
councillor dawson yes
yeah i i agree actually without
councillor gould would say i'm not quite
sure and with council a bit why we're
actually doing this
and i'm not too concerned um
you know what other councils doing
because other councils don't offer free
car parking which hopefully into you
course we will continue to do um you all
know my feelings on that and you know at
the end of the day what we don't want to
be doing we've got to really look at
these finances really closely and my
feeling is if we sort of say to somebody
would you like a subsidy of course
they're going to say yes
you know i would um but 150 pounds when
you're training you know think of what
students play when they go to do their
degrees at university in a year so it
strikes me 150 pounds actually
is it yes it's nice but actually that
money i i
sort of believe could be spent probably
in other places in
in a much better way perhaps
so i'd be finding it quite difficult to
perhaps
endorse this actually thank you
councillor dawson and it has been it has
been my suggestion
has anyone else any comment to make on
this
no
would
do we need to propose it or are we just
going to
vote and see
chairman i'll make a proposal then to
help you
but we don't uh we don't offer this um
discount
thank you um legal officer
there was a proposal on the table
there's a proposal thank you there's a
proposal on the table that we do not
offer it is there a seconder for that
councillor dawson
how do we do the vote karen on this one
please
would you like to do it electronically
electronically or by hand
we can do a vote
on what we're voting on we can do a show
of hands if that's easier
the legal officer has said a show of
hands are members happy with that
councillor gould could i just say that
we're not offering it
um the showing what we were saying was
that we were going to
suggest that cabinet discusses it so
we're actually not offering
this but i've had a proposal
sorry
that we don't propose this to the
cabinet
your proposal is that we do not
are you happy with that council of gold
that makes more sense right yes thank
you very much
thank you so if we can counsel a
carpenter
say i think in view of some confusion
here
might be helpful if the governance
officer actually read out the actual
recommendation that we've got
thank you it's not well it's not a
recommendation it's a it's a proposal
do we need to do that legal officer
well to be honest you could probably
choose not to vote on it i mean if it's
decided that you don't think it's going
to be
a successful
proposal on your behalf to to recommend
it accounts first cabinet
if you feel that there is not going to
be the support here
i mean you could just drop the proposal
okay and close the meeting
councillor coppendale i think it would
be
helpful if cabinet were made aware of
our concerns
and that we had considerable discussion
about it
but perhaps in the event didn't feel
that we should make a proposal or
recommendation to them but i do think it
would be good if in in the narrative
um we alerted cabinet to the fact that
there were some concerns about the
impact on existing drivers in the short
term
thank
um you and governance officer can we do
that well that could be done just by way
of minuting
conversation thank you very much thank
you
so um
we are we have some concerns about um
the suggestion that i put forward but we
will minute
that
we have discussed it and we are
concerned about the cost to the taxi
trade
um and so on this occasion we will just
now drop
my suggestion and i'm very happy with
that but thank you everyone for
listening
is that okay legal officer
yes
that's fine
so um we've extended the meeting
slightly so we now close um the meeting
at um
something like 2 58
and
thank you very much all for attending um
we appreciate councillor dawson
making the effort to attend at the end
of the meeting so thank you very much
thank you